c'était en mai 2018 le maire de ducos
sommet par le préfet de faire
interrompre les travaux de marie vialle
dans sa commune prenait la défense des
promoteurs nous avons un pouvoir
d'initiative privée ça bien mais de
construire ça passe quand même un
problème c'est votre autorité qui est
bafouée une défense qui lui vaut
aujourd'hui d'être renvoyé devant le
tribunal correctionnel lui et neuf
autres personnes
le patron de hma divialle les consos
riot propriétaire du terrain mais aussi
l'entreprise et l'architecte qui ont
fait les travaux une décision du
procureur dans un dossier qui selon lui
a multiplié les écueils dans un premier
temps on a cette construction qui est
réalisé sans aucun permis de construire
et dans un second temps nous avons une
construction qui a et qui c'est qui
s'est poursuivie sur la base d'un permis
de construire qui de toute évidence ne
respecte pas le plan local d'urbanisme
de la commune du causse notamment parce
que il s'agit d'une construction qui n'a
pas une vocation agricole et qui est
construite en zone agricole est par
ailleurs une construction qui d'une
hauteur donc de plus de 20 mètres alors
que la hauteur limite et donc deux fois
inférieur pour la sopa marque avait
alerté depuis 2018 c'est une double
victoire cette semaine
le permis de construire accordé
rétrospectivement par la commune de
ducos a lui aussi été annulé par le
tribunal administratif la sopam arts
souhaite à présent obtenir la remise en
état du site
l'étape d'après c'est donc de demander
la remise en état des lieux de façon
judiciaire et
le silo à grains n'a plus rien à faire
là les propriétaires doivent le démonter
et s'ils ne veulent pas le faire faut
qu'il soit condamné à le faire c'est une
activité agricole qui doit être sur sept
terrains agricoles
on manque de terrains agricoles en
service en martinique on a du terrain
qui est impactée par le chlordécone
on est en train de repenser la manière
dont on va passer à l'après banane on
peut pas on peut pas passer à
l'industrialisation à outrance le
tribunal correctionnel pourrait bien
ordonné la destruction du bâtiment c'est
en tout cas la requête du procureur
chacun des protagonistes risque jusqu'à
trois cents mille euros d'amande et un
million 5 pour les entreprises
un casse tête de plus pour la
coopérative mahdi vial par ailleurs sous
le coup d'une enquête judiciaire pour
détournement de fonds européens